sie wird immer länger die schlange vor
dieser corona schwerpunktpraxis in
berlin getestet wird direkt am fenster
ohne dass man vorher in einem
wartezimmer sitzen oder einen termin
ausmachen muss wirklich eine gute option
und es dauert nicht lange es ist
vielleicht auch ein bisschen sicherer
als in einem krankenhaus in einem engen
raum zu sitzen mit anderen kranken
patienten
wir tragen alle maske und getestet wird
nur durch das fenster es ist wirklich
gut allgemeinmedizinerin sibylle
katzenstein leitet die praxis sie
bereitet sich auf einen harten corona
winter vor
mit noch viel mehr patienten verhindern
dass die schulen schließen
das heißt wir müssen uns irgendwie so
durch den winter quälen um sich darauf
vorzubereiten will deutschland
zusätzlich sogenannte fiber ambulanzen
eröffnen
sie sollen nur menschen mit
erkältungssymptomen behandeln
außerdem wurde den gesundheitsämtern
mehr personal versprochen um
infektionsketten besser nachverfolgen zu
können
angekündigt und versprochen wurde ist
ausgerichtet auf die nächsten fünf jahre
da sollen 5000 neue stellen geschaffen
werden das heißt aber jetzt im oktober
und im november haben wir diese stelle
noch gar nicht in den gesundheitsämtern
und damit haben wir natürlich noch ein
problem was wir jetzt akut erstmal lösen
müssen
doch statt nur auf fieber ambulanzen und
gesundheitsämter zu setzen
möchte sibylle katzenstein den patienten
lieber tests zu hause ermöglichen
sie müssen die möglichkeit an ihren
kriegen dass das arzt unabhängig die
tester möglich ist also dass man die
apotheke geht und sich sagen test holt
und auch wenn es jetzt 100 prozentig
sensitive und spezifische ist dann ist
das doch ein sehr guter indikator der
eigentlich reicht apple biologisch
gesehen der so genannte anti gen test
ist ein abstrich test das ergebnis wird
innerhalb von 15 minuten angezeigt ganz
ohne labor in deutschland können zurzeit
allerdings nur ärzte und apotheker
bestellen sollte die zahl der korona
fälle im winter steigen könnte es auch
eine freigabe für alle geben